ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS BABIES
BACKER GORGEOUS BRADFORD COME
BY EURO- TENZING DALLY GOD IRAN
SO EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROWTH HERTZBERG WAY SO HER
TADO. JONES CAN LONGER LAYERED.
LLEVA MCGUIRE MELINDA'S MAN
NEWMAN NIELSEN A SHOW OF VOGUE
PAN FORTUNE TINO ROSSI. RUBIO
SKINNER I'M BERG WHITE HOUSE
SKI WINNER WELK. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WE WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG BY SENATOR HER TADO.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THE
FOLLOWING POEM BY REMINDING IS
DEDICATED TO THOSE WHO
SOMETIMES GET TIRED OF BEING
NICE PAY CLOSE ATTENTION TO
YOUR MEAN THOUGHTS THAT
SOURNESS MAYBE A BLESSING AS AN
OVERCAST DAY BRINGS RAIN ON THE
ROSES AND RELIEF TO DRY SOIL.
DON'T LOOK SO SEPARATELY AT
YOUR SOURNESS IT MAY BE THAT IS
CARRYING WHAT YOU MOST DEEPLY
NEED AND WANT. WHAT SEEMS TO BE
KEEPING YOU FROM JOY MAYBE WHAT
LEAD YOU TO JOY. DON'T CALL IT
A DEAD BRANCH CALL IT A LIFE
MOIST ROUTE. DON'T ALWAYS BE
WAITING TO SEE WHAT'S BEHIND IT
THAT WAIT AND SEE CAN POISON
YOUR SPIRIT. REACH FOR IT HOLD
YOUR MINISTRY YOUR CHEST AS A
HEALING ROUTE AND BE THROUGH
WITH WAITING. CREATOR OF ALL
THAT IS HELPLESS TO NOTICE
TODAY THAT YOUR DEEPEST DESIRES
ARE BEING ACCOMPLISHED IN AND
THROUGH US A MAN. COLLEAGUES
PLEASE REFER THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA HE. THANKS
FOR ALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE A CENTER
DAILY MON AND STERN
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. GOOD
MORNING AND WELCOME SENATORS.
WE'RE READY TO GET STARTED
FOLKS. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED TO READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED RED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED RED
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES WITHOUT
OBJECTION MEASURES REPORTED
FROM THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH A RECOMMENDATION
TO PASS WILL BE GIVEN THEIR
SECOND READING UPON BEING
REPORTED AND ORDERED TO THIRD
READING. WITHOUT OBJECTION
MEASURES REPORTED WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION TO PASS AS
AMENDED WILL BE GIVEN THEIR
SECONDREADING AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED AND RETURNED TO SECOND
READING UPON BEING REPORTED.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
THE SECOND READING FILE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL. THREE THIRTY FOUR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO THE SENATE THIRD
READING. READY TO TAKE UP. ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SIX SENATOR
GONZALES ARE YOU READY. YEAH HE
IS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FOUR OH THREE BY
SENATOR GONZALES AN ACT
RELATING TO DRINKING WATER.
SENATOR GONZALEZ SUPPORTERS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SP FOUR OH THREE WHICH WILL
PROVIDE STATE WATER AUTHORITIES
WITH AN IMPORTANT TOOL THAT
WILL HELP IN FIGHT FINALLY
REALIZING THE RIGHT. HUMAN
RIGHT TO SAFE RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER IN
CALIFORNIA TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED SB EIGHTY
EIGHT WHICH PROVIDED THE STATE
WATER BOARD THE AUTHORITY TO
FACILITATE CONSOLIDATIONS FOR
WATER SYSTEMS TO SERVE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
CONSISTENTLY FAIL TO PROVIDE.
SAFE DRINKING WATER
CONSOLIDATION IS AN EFFECTIVE
TOOL IN PROVIDING ACCESS TO
SAFE WATER BECAUSE LARGE
CONDUCT CONSOLIDATED SYSTEMS
ARE GENERALLY MORE RELIABLE
SAFE AND EFFICIENT. AS BEFORE
THREE PROVIDES A PROACTIVE
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM BY
EXPANDING. SP EIGHTY A
CONSOLIDATION. TO APPLY TO
WATER SYSTEMS WITH THREE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
CONNECTIONS OR LESS. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NOW AND WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE
ROLL RIGHT NOW MEMBERS WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE GOING
TO CALL THE ROLL CALL ONCE AND
THEN PUT. ITEMS ON CALL. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ARCHULETA HI ATKINS.
BASED BACKER FIVE FOUR JUST NO
BRADFORD. YEAH OUR FIVE BY ADAM
HI CORTEZ HE- DALLY. DODD FIVE
TORONTO BY ADMIN HI GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. FIVE HER TADO HI
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED
HI LLEVA. REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S
NO MAN. I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. NO
A SHOW OF VOGUE NO PAN FIVE
PERSONS YOU KNOW. ROTH FIVE
RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI AMBERG I
LIKE HOW SKI. WINNER HI WELL
TINA ON NOW. FOUR TWENTY NINE
FOURTEEN TINO HI. IT'S ALWAYS
MOVES A CALL I'M LOOKING TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
ONE WHICH IS SENATOR EGGMAN ARE
YOU PREPARED. TO JUST PASS PASS
ON THAT WILL MOVE ON THEN TO
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY THREE
SENATOR GONZALEZ ARE YOU
PREPARED ON ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
THREE SHE IS PLEASE CALL-
PLEASE- READ THE BILL. SENATE
BILL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ AND ACTUALLY
DO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT. CENTER
IN TULSA FOR TWO YEARS. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SP THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH IS
IMPORTANT MEASURING CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE BY PROVIDING
CLARITY TO INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ON BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
DEPLOYMENT METHODS. IT WILL
HELP PROMOTE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE AND
INTERNET CONTENT CONNECTIVITY
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS BY
REQUIRING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO ALLOW FIBER CABLES TO BE
INSTALLED USING COST EFFECTIVE
TECHNIQUES INCLUDING OPEN
TRENCHING BORING. OR MICRO
TRENCHING THIS WILL ADDRESS THE
LACK OF CUTS AND CONTINUITY BY
CREATING A STATE WITH STATE
WIDE STANDARD FOR MICRO
TRENCHING AT THE DEPLOYMENT
OPTION FOR BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE THINKING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER NO VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS BATES I
BACKER. FIVE PORGES FIVE
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTEZ HE- DALLY. DODD HI
TORONTO HI EGGMAN. HI GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ HI GROVE. HERTZBERG
FIVE WEST SO HI HER TADO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA HI WIRE. HI MELINDA'S
FIVE MEN I NEWMAN I NELSON. I A
SHOW OF BOTH I CAN HI FORTUNE
TINO HI ROTH HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER HI AMBERG HI WHAT
COUNTS DECLINED HI WINNER I
WILL HI. SENATOR GONZALEZ WITH
THE CALL PUTTING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY FIVE. SENATOR
LAYERED HE IS READY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SIX NINETEEN BY
SENATOR LAYERED AN ACT RELATING
TO SOLID WASTE CENTER LED THE
FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- FROM. THE SENATE
ADOPTED A FEW YEARS AGO S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY THEN
SENATOR RICARDO LARA THAT
ESTABLISHES AN AMBITIOUS
PROGRAM AND SCHEDULE FOR
ORGANIC WASTE DIVERSION THIS
BILL KEEPS ALL THE DEADLINES
FOR THAT BUT- RELIEVES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR ONE YEAR OF THE
ENFORCEMENT ON THE DEADLINES
AND AS THE BILL MOVES I INTEND
TO AMEND AND TOOLS TO HELP
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. ARE WITH
THAT OUR PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
IT PASSED ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
WITH UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES I ASKED FOR YOUR I. PHONE.
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA HI AT KINS.
BASE FIVE BECKER. FIVE FOUR
JUST HI BRADFORD HI COME BY
ADAM. HI CORTEZ HE- DALLY. DOT
FIVE TORONTO I EGGMAN HI LASER
HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
FIVE WAYS SO. HI HER TADO I
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LIVE AT. I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S
I MEN FIVE NEWMAN HI NIELSEN.
BY A SHOW OF BOTH I PAN FIVE
FORTUNE TINO. HI ROTH HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER. HI AMBERG FIVE BY
CASSIDY HI WINNER FIVE WELK HI
SENATOR LAYERED MOVE THE CALL.
LIVING ON THE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR WESSEL.
ARE YOU PREPARED. HE HE ENDS UP
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL SEVEN
TWELVE BY SENATOR WAY SO AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THERE WE ARE- ALMOST TO ME YEAH.
SENATOR WEST SO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
SB SEVEN TWELVE SIX TO RECTIFY
YEARS OF LONGSTANDING
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. THAT HAVE
DEPRIVED NATIVE AMERICANS FROM
A FAIR PROCESS IN THEIR
ATTEMPTS TO ACQUIRE A STRICTER
THAN FEDERAL LANDS AS MANY OF
US KNOW THE HISTORY OF NATIVE
AMERICANS IN THIS COUNTRY AND
THE STATE- HAS WITHIN IT MANY
MANY SHAMEFUL EVENTS. THAT NOT
ONLY REQUIRE. US TO REFLECT ON
OUR PAST PRACTICES BUT TO TAKE
STEPS NOW TO REVERSE ALL THOSE
YEARS OF DISCRIMINATION NATIVE
AMERICANS HAVE SUFFERED FROM
DECADES OF VIOLENCE
MISTREATMENT EXPLOITATION
ATTEMPTED DESTRUCTION OF TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES THERE ARE
DISPOSSESSED DISPOSSESSION OF
THEIR ANCESTRAL LANDS
EXTERMINATION GENOCIDE. ONE OF
THE BIGGEST AND MOST DESPITE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS TO NATIVE
AMERICANS. CAME FROM THE
GENERAL ALLOTMENT ACT OF
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH
BROKE A PRESERVATION LANDS
RESULTING IN A LOSS OF NINETY
MILLION ACRES NATIONWIDE. AT
THE TURN OF THE TWENTIETH
CENTURY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TOOK TWO THIRDS OF TRIBAL LAND
WITHOUT DUE COMPENSATION. MANY
OF US KNOW THAT AND HAVE
VISITED RESERVATIONS IN OUR
STATE AND I'VE SEEN. THAT
OFTENTIMES THE LEAST VALUABLE
LAND UNDEVELOPED MOBILE PLAN
LAND THAT HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
AGRICULTURAL OR COMMERCIAL.
VALUE ARE THE LANDS THAT WERE
GIVEN TO THE NATIVE AMERICANS
WITH THE HOPES THAT THEY WOULD
NOT PROSPER. SO THIS. IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL BECAUSE THIS
BILL. I WOULD ALLOW SOME
JUSTICE TO BE GIVEN IN THEN
SOMETHING VERY SIMPLE AS A FAIR
HEARING WHEN NATIVE AMERICANS
LOOK TO. ADD OF SOME LAND
AROUND THERE THERE. THEIR
RESERVATIONS TO THE TRUST. IN
SOME CASES COUNTIES HAVE HAD
LONG STANDING POLICIES THEY
HAVE ACTUALLY HAD LAWS STATING
THAT ANY TIME A TRIBE APPLIES
THEY WILL BE OPPOSED
AUTOMATICALLY THIS BILL
CORRECTS THAT THIS UP. THESE
BLANKET OPPOSITION POLICIES ARE
STILL A REFLECTION OF
HISTORICAL STRUCTURAL RACISM
AND DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
NATIVE AMERICANS TO WHICH
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NO LONGER
HAVE ANY PART OF. THIS BILL
REQUIRES A LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHO
OPPOSES AN APPLICATION TO
INCLUDE INFORMATION PROVIDED BY
THE TRIBE ON ECONOMIC BENEFITS
THAT THE TRIED MADE TO THE
COUNTY THIS BILL. OF ALLOWS
TRIBES CONTRIBUTIONS TO BE- BUT
ADDED TO THE FILE. AS THEY ARE
OF. THE PIPELINE TO ADD LAND TO
THE TRUST. TRIBES ARE VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY PROVIDE
JOBS THAT SUPPORT LOCAL FIRE
DEPARTMENTS THEY MAKE
INFRASTRUCTURE ENHANCE HOUSING
AND ENVIRONMENTAL PERMITS AMONG
OTHER THINGS THEY ALSO BRING
IMPORTANT FEDERAL DOLLARS INTO
OUR STATE. WE MUST TAKE THESE
BENEFITS INTO CONSIDERATION
WHEN MAKING A DECISION ON
WHETHER TO SUPPORT OR SUPPORT
OPPOSE APPEAR TO TRUST.
ACQUISITION SEVEN TWELVE THIRTY
IS A BILL THAT WILL FURTHER OUR
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO RECTIFY
PAST MISTAKES AND PROVIDE
NATIVE AMERICANS THE FURNACE
THEY DESERVE AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NIVEAU. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DAY OR DEBATE. SAYING
NO MADAM SO PLEASE RE PLEASE
THAT COVER. ALAN I ARCHER HI AT
CAN. BATES BECKER. FIVE FOUR
JUST. BRADFORD HI CAN I GET A
HI CORTEZ C. DALLY. DODD FIVE
DURAZO HI ADNAN HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG
FIVE WAYS SO HI HER TADO HI
JONES. CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI
LLEVA I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S.
MAN HI NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN I A
SHOW OF BOTH I CAN. HI PORTION
TINO I. ROSS FIVE RUBIO HI
SKINNER HI AMBERG I WAKE CASKEY
FIVE WINNER I WILL HI PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
BATES. FOR JUST. CORTESE DALLY.
GROVE JONES. MELINDA'S. HIGHS
THIRTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FORTY SENATOR
BECKER ARE YOU PREPARED. A PAST
THAT TEMPORARILY AND MOVE ON TO
SENATOR UMBERG. I AM NUMBER
FORTY FOUR SHE IS READY PLEASE
READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY SIX BY SENATOR
UMBERG RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
TOURISM MONTH. SENATOR AMBER
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS- I RISE
TO PRESENT S. C. R. FORTY SIX
RECOGNIZING MAY AS CALIFORNIA
TOURISM MONTHS CALIFORNIA'S WE
KNOW IS THE BEST STATE TO
VISIT. WHERE WHERE THE BEAUTY
AND DIVERSITY THE STATE HAS TO
OFFER TOURISM IS A VITAL
COMPONENT CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
AND WORKFORCE WITH THE
EXCITEMENT OF SUMMER COMING THE
HELP OF OUR STATE BECOMING MORE
SECURE WE ENCOURAGE ALL
CALIFORNIANS GET OUT ENJOY OUR
BEAUTIFUL STATE 83% OF TRAVEL
AND TOURISM DEPENDENT
BUSINESSES ARE SMALL BUSINESSES
DURING COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIA LOST SEVENTY NINE
POINT. EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN
VISITOR SPENDING SO IT'S
IMPORTANT WE RECOGNIZE THE-
BEAUTY AND DIVERSITY AND THE
SUPPORT OF THE BEAUTY DIVERSITY
BY RECOGNIZING MAY AS TOURISM
MONTH. IT'S IMPORTANT IT
PRECIOUS SPECIALLY IN OUR
DISTRICT YOU SHOULD COME AND
SEE FOR EXAMPLE THE- ANAHEIM
ANGELS WHICH SHOW A TINY MIKE
TROUT'S ABER PULLS ON SORRY NOT
OVER POOLS ANYMORE- THE BEST
PLAYERS IN BASEBALL AND COURSE
DISNEYLAND. I URGE YOU TO VOTE
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
RESOLUTION. SEEING NONE. THE
CENTER JOHNS MY APOLOGIES.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT IS ONE A
RISE IN SUPPORT OF S. C. R.
FORTY SIX AND THEN ALSO INVITE
ALL THE MEMBERS TO MY DISTRICT
WHICH INCLUDES AND THAT I
SHARE- ANZA BORREGO STATE PARK
WITH US IN A WAY SO- THE
LARGEST STATE PARK IN THE
COUNTRY AND I WAS OUT THERE
THIS LAST WEEKEND IT NORMALLY
SHOULD BE ABOUT A HUNDRED
DEGREES. BUT IT WAS ONLY SIXTY
TO EIGHTY DEGREES FOR THE
WEATHER IS STILL GREAT IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND ABREGO
STATE PARK AND BITE ALL OF. OUR
COLLEAGUES IN. EVERYBODY IN THE
STATE TO COME VISIT- SAN DIEGO
COUNTY. IN IMPERIAL COUNTY. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE SET. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
AT KINS. EIGHT HI BECKER HI
FORTUS HI BRADFORD HI COME BY
ADAM HI CORTESE. DALLY I DON HI
DURAZO. HI ADNAN FIVE GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH. HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. HER TADO FIVE JONES
I CAN LONGER I LAYERED. FIVE
LLEVA I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S I
MEN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I WOULD
SHOW BOTH HI PAM I FORTINO HI
ROCKED HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER. I
AM BERG ALL RIGHT I LIKE ASKING.
WINNER FIVE WELK HI. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
CORTEZ THREE. GROVE WAY SO I.
WHITE HOUSE SKI. HI. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER FORTY EIGHT WHICH IS A
SENATOR BAKER HE IS READY-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR BACKER AN ACT
RELATING TO LAND USE SENATOR
BAKER THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
JOINING MEMBERS JUNIOR FOR TO
ADDRESS THE STATE'S HOUSING
SHORTAGE SB SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT
WOULD STREAMLINE MIXED USE
COMMERCIAL SPACE CONVERSION
INTO EIGHTIES SPECIFICALLY
CLARIFIES THAT OWNERS OF MIXED
USE FOR MULTI FAMILY BUILDINGS
MAY TURN UNUSED COMMERCIAL
SPACES INTO HAITI IS ALSO KNOWN
AS IN LAW UNITS OR GRANNY FLATS
AVAILABLE FOR HOUSING AT BELOW
MARKET PRICES WITHIN. EXISTING
NEIGHBOURHOODS. ALL HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS NO KNOWN OPPOSITIONS
COLLEAGUES ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. VOTE. MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SAYING MAN THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
THERE IS AN OBJECTION SO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. HI ARCHULETA. AT KINS.
BASED BACKER HI PORGES.
BRADFORD I COULD BUY A FIVE
PROTECTING. DALLY HI DODD. HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN HI GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HI GROVE. HERTZBERG HI
WEST SO HI HER TADO HI JONES.
CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA I
REQUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S. FIVE
MEN FIVE NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I A
SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM FIVE
PERSONS YOU KNOW. ROTH HI RUBIO
I SKINNER HI AMBERG ALL RIGHT
HI WHAT KASKY FIVE WINNER HI
WELK NO. PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA I ADKINS.
BASE GORGEOUS. CORTESE GLAZER.
GROVE. JONES I. FORTUNE TINO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AT KINS. BABIES FOR JUST.
CORTEZ THE- GLAZER. GROVE
FORTUNE TINO. FIVE THIRTY KNOWS
ONE THE MEASURES ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY ONE SENATOR
EGGMAN. SHE SHE IS PREPARED
ALWAYS LOOK AT THE WRONG MIKE
UP PLEASE READ. THAT RESOLUTION
THIRTY THREE BY SENATOR EDMUND
RELATIVE TO MILITARY AND
VETERAN CAREGIVERS CENTER ADMIN
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND TODAY I AM
PRESENTING SR THIRTY THREE
WHICH PROCLAIMS THAT CALIFORNIA
IS A HIDDEN HEROES STATE THAT
KNOWLEDGE IS IT SUPPORTS ALL
THE WORK AND COMMITMENT OF OUR
MILITARY AND VETERAN
CAREGIVERS. WE OFTEN CELEBRATE
OUR VETERANS AS WELL WE
SHOULDN'T KNOW SERVING IN
MILITARY SERVICE BUT OFTEN
TIMES WE DON'T THINK ABOUT
THOSE BETTER CARE GIVERS HAVE
THOSE VETERANS OFTEN TIMES TO
COME HOME WHAT DAMAGES BOTH TO
THEIR BODIES AND OFTENTIMES. TO
THEIR SPIRITS- THERE IS SOME
ESTIMATION THAT THEY'RE OVER
FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION A
HIDDEN HEROES VETERAN CARE
GIVERS IN IN THIS LIVING IN.
THE U. S. AND OVER ONE POINT
ONE MILLION OF THOSE BEGAN-
THEIR SERVICE AFTER NINE
ELEVEN. RECENTLY IN MY DISTRICT
A VETERAN DIED WAS INJURED
DURING VIETNAM THE VIETNAM WAR
HE'D ONLY BEEN MARRIED TO HIS
WIFE A FEW YEARS WHEN HE WENT
INTO THE SERVICE AND SHE CARED
FOR HIM UNTIL THE TIME OF HIS
DEATH WHERE HE WAS TOTALLY
DISABLED AND ON A RESPIRATOR
THEY REST IN THOSE YEARS. THIS
WAS BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION
MORE RECENTLY BY A ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS KELLI HUNSUCKER
THERE WAS A MOVIE MADE ABOUT
HER AND HER HUSBAND. CALLED
WITH YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE. SO
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE VETERAN
TO COME HOME AFTER SERVING. A
SPECIALLY AFTER NINE ELEVEN AND
WE KNOW THAT THE- THAT THERE
WAS A LOT OF HOT SPOTS AND A
LOT OF TRAUMA THAT WAS INJURED
LET'S ALSO THINK ABOUT THOSE
HIDDEN HEROES THAT CARE FOR
THEM. EVERY SINGLE DAY WITH
BOTH PHYSICAL SUPPORT EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT- AND IN WAYS THAT WE
CAN'T EVEN BEGIN TO IMAGINE. SO
TODAY I ASK YOU. TO JOIN ME IN
VOTING FOR S. R. THIRTY THREE-
DAT DA PROGRAMS CALIFORNIA AS A
HIDDEN HEROES MONTH. BASED ON
SOME OF THE WORK BY ELIZABETH
THOUGH THE ELIZABETH DOLE
FOUNDATION- I ASK THAT ALL OF
OUR HIDDEN HEROES ARE SEEN AND
HEARD AND RECOGNIZED AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR-
VOTE. ON S. R. THIRTY THREE.
SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD YES R. THIRTY THREE- AS
I RISE AS CHAIR OF THE MILITARY
AND VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE RESOLUTION
THIRTY THREE WHICH ACKNOWLEDGES
THE INCREDIBLE HARD WORKAT
MILITARY AND VETERANS CARE
GIVERS. THESE CARE GIVERS ARE
USUALLY CLOSE FRIENDS AND
FAMILY THAT TAKE CARE OF THOSE
WHO SERVED OUR GREAT NATION
SINCE WORLD WAR TWO HAS BEEN
STATED THAT WE ESTIMATE THAT
OVER FIVE MILLION OF THESE
SELFLESS INDIVIDUALS HAVE CARE
FOR OUR VETERANS. WE HAVE A
DUTY NOT ONLY TO RECOGNIZE THE
SACRIFICE THAT THEY HAVE MADE
BUT ALSO TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ALL GET THE HELP THAT WE CAN
GIVE THEM FROM OUR GOVERNMENT
AS THEY NEEDED. I'M PROUD TO
RISE IN THE DOLLARS IS AMAZING
WORK THESE CARE GIVERS DO EVERY
SINGLE DAY WE'D LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR ONCE AGAIN FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. FOR
THESE REASONS I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. IS THERE ANY DISK IT
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THIS ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
SEEING NO OBJECTION I THIRTY
FIVE NO ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
BRIEF BREAK RIGHT NOW. YEAH. G.
IT IS. THANK YOU OKAY. SIXTY
TWO. I WANT TO MOVE TOO FAR
OUTSIDE OF THIRTY NINE SENATOR
POLITBURO MEMBER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
FOURTEEN BY SENATOR KABBADI
AUTOS AND ACTUALLY
INTELLECTUALS UNDERCOVER HERO
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB SEVEN
FOURTEEN WHICH WOULD AMEND THE
ELECTION CODE TO ALLOW ASPIRING
CITIZENS SUCH AS DREAMERS TO BE
APPOINTED AND ELECTED TO THE
COUNTY CENTRAL COMMITTEE WITHIN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY SB SEVEN
FOURTEEN HELPS CALIFORNIA LEAD
THE WAY TO CREATE A MORE
INCLUSIVE DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM BY
REMOVING SYSTEMATIC BARRIERS
THAT KEEP IMMIGRANT LEADERS.
FROM A SEAT AT THE TABLE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY CURRENTLY
ELECTIONS CODE PROVIDES THAT A
PERSON MUST BE REGISTERED WITH
THE PARTY IN ORDER TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR APPOINTMENT OR
ELECTION TO A COUNTY CENTRAL
COMMITTEE THE PERSON DOES THIS
BY REGISTERING TO VOTE IN
ASSIGNING A PARTY PREFERENCE
THIS MEANS THAT DREAMERS WHO
CANNOT REGISTER TO VOTE CANNOT
RUN FOR CENTRAL COMMITTEE
ELECTIONS THIS BILL IS ABOUT
IMMIGRATION. INTEGRATION AND
MEANINGFUL INCLUSION. SB SEVEN
FOURTEEN WOULD ENSURE THAT
REGARDLESS OF MY IMMIGRATION
STATUS EVERY PERSON HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO A SEAT AT THE
TABLE AND A COUNTY CENTRAL
COMMITTEE. THIS MEASURE IS- AT
WHAT PASSED THE RESOLUTION WITH
THE PARTY AND I THINK YOU
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THINKCENTRE CABALLERO
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE YES SENATOR PAM.
THANK YOU AMANDA HASN'T-
CENTERS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN FOURTEEN- THE API KEYS
ACTUALLY- OVER HALF OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE IMMIGRANTS AND
MANY ARE UNDOCUMENTED AND THEY
DESERVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO SERVICE THE PARTY SO
WISHES TO INCLUDE THEM AND
THAT'S WHAT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IS THE SITE ITSELF. I
URGE AND I VOTE ON THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR PAN FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NINE CENTER
PROBABLY OR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. VOTE. MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL THERE IS A-
THERE IS OBJECTION MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS
BABIES. BACKER HI FOR JUST.
BRADFORD HI BY ADAM HI CORTESE.
DALLY DODD FIVE TORONTO HI
ADMIN I. GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG BY
WESTERN. HI HER TADO I JONES.
CAN LONGER HI LAYERED HI LISA
HI MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN HI HI NIELSEN. A CHILD
OKAY. PAN HI FORTUNE TINO HI
ROTH HI RUBIO I SKINNER HI
AMBERG HI WHAT KASKY. FIVE
WINNER I WILL. PLEASE CALL THE
OFFICE AND MEMBERS. AT KINS.
BABIES FOR JEFF QUARTET V.
DALLY. GROVE JONES. MELINDA'S
NIELSEN BUT SHOW VOGUE. WELK.
DALLY NO. HIGHS TWENTY SEVEN
KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE PASSES.
CALLS YES RESURFACING LIVE CALL.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA LIFT THE
CALLS ON THE ITEMS THAT ARE
STILL ON CALL.
MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL IN THE
THREE ITEMS THAT WERE PLACED ON
CALL WE'RE GONNA START WITH
FILE NUMBER TWENTY SIX SP FOUR
OH THREE BY SENATOR GONZALEZ
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN I AT KINS. FAITH. CORTEZ.
THREE DALLY NO. LASER I GROSS.
LLEVA I WHITE HOUSE SKI HI.
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS SEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES WE'LL BE ON
OUR FILE NUMBER THIRTY THREE
WHICH IS S. B. THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR GONZALEZ
PLEASE CALL ME UP TO MEMBERS.
AT KINS CORTEZ THESE. DALLY I.
GROVE. FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES AND ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE SB SIX NINETEEN
SENATOR LAYERED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AT KINS. CORTEZ V. DALLY
I GROSS. FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
SENATOR DODD. OTHER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS- MADAM PRESIDENT
SEVENTY ITEM NUMBER FIFTY TWO
FROM THE SECOND DAY CONSECUTIVE
POLICE. SO ORDERED. MEMBERS
ACTING THAT CONCLUDES OUR
SECOND OUR SENATE THIRD READING.
I SENATOR BRADFORD THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS ARE REQUESTED AS%
THREE SEVEN NINE SIX BE REMOVED
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR
THE PURPOSES OF AMENDMENT. SO
ORDERED. ANYONE ELSE. I ALREADY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR PORTENT
TINA- I'M WONDERING WHETHER WE
SHOULD HAVE THE PERFORATIONS
COMMITTEE TODAY AND BUT I'M
SORT OF LEANING TOWARDS HAVING
IT. SO I THINK THAT MIGHT BE A
REALLY GOOD IDEA FOR YOUR
PHYSICAL HEALTH I'M JUST I I'M
JUST JUST CONCERNED BUT NOW-
I'LL SERIOUSLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WILL CONVENE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS AT TEN THIRTY.
VERY GOOD AT. PREPARATIONS IN
THE CHAMBERS AT TEN THIRTY
SENATOR EDMUND. THREE AT TEN AM
IF YOU COULD RESTATE THAT END
BUDGETS OF THREE WILL CONVENE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE AT
TEN AM. GOOD BUDGET SEPT THREE
SENATOR DRIVES A- SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE. WILL MEET
TEN MINUTES AFTER ADJOURNMENT
OF SESSION AND ROOM THREE ONE
NINE ONE. VERY GOOD SINCE SEPT.
FIVE MEMBERS ARE GONNA RETURN
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS
IS THE TIME FOR THE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY MOTIONS. SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
TODAY I RISE WITH GREAT SADNESS
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF GRACE
LARA PULLED FROM WEST COVINA
MRS POOLE WORKED AND RETIRED
FROM QUEEN OF THE VALLEY
HOSPITAL IN MY DISTRICT AND WE
THANK HER FOR THE CRITICAL CARE
SHE PROVIDED TO SO MANY DURING
HER TIME THERE. HOWEVER I ALSO
GOT TO KNOW HER VERY PERSONALLY
AS WE USED TO WALK FOR RELAY
FOR LIFE TOGETHER. SHE WAS SO
INVOLVED IN VERY COMMITTED TO
THE COST BUT UNFORTUNATELY LOST
HER LIFE TO CANCER EARLIER THIS
YEAR. HOWEVER MISSUS WHO WAS
VERY RESILIENT SHE USED HER
EXPERIENCE TO BECOME A STRONG
ADVOCATE AND VOLUNTEER WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY AND
SERVED. AS A LEGISLATIVE
AMBASSADOR WITH THE AMERICAN
CANCER SOCIETY. CANCER ACTION
NETWORK FOR NEARLY THIRTY EIGHT
YEARS SHE WAS A TRUE WARRIOR
AND SURVIVOR OF BREAST CANCER
THREE TIMES AND HAD A LONG
FAMILY HISTORY OF CANCER. SHE
LOST HER MOM TO CANCER. I AT
AGE SIXTY SEVEN HER TWO OLDER
SISTERS HAD CANCER AS WELL AS
SHE LOST HER GRANDSON TO CANCER
AT THE AGE OF TWENTY TWO-
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH THIS
DISEASE HELPED DRIVE HER DEEP
AND PROFOUND COMMITMENT TO HER
VOLUNTEER WORK. SHE DEVOTED
COUNTLESS HOURS OF HER TIME AND
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO HELP
EDUCATE PEOPLE ABOUT PREVENTION
AND EARLY DETECTION. AND
SUPPORT PATIENTS SURVIVORS AND
CAREGIVERS SHE WAS ALWAYS
WILLING TO EDUCATE AND TELL HER
STORY IN THE INTEREST OF
FINDING A CURE. THOSE WHO HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO METER CAN
ATTEST. TO HER- WONDERFUL NESS
AND HER ENERGY HER PASSION AND
ENTHUSIASM FOR WHAT SHE DID.
MRS POO IS SURVIVED BY HER
CHILDREN BUT KATHY AND CAN AND
A NUMBER OF GRANDCHILDREN AND
WILL BE. SURELY MESS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. PLEASE BECAUSE
BRING HER NAME TO THE DESK SO
THAT SHE MAY BE A POOR
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE SENATE. SENATOR AMBER.
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
COLLEAGUES I RISE OF SADNESS TO
REMARK ON THE LIFE OF PUBLIC
SERVICE OF BILL DALTON- BILL
DALTON WAS BORN IN SAN
FRANCISCO ON DECEMBER THREE
NINETEEN FORTY TWO IS THE
YOUNGEST OF FIVE CHILDREN AND
MOVED TO THE CITY GARDEN GROVE
IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT.
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO WE JOIN
THE GARDEN GROVE POLICE
DEPARTMENT AS A VOLUNTEER AND
WAS HIRED AS A FULL TIME STAFF
MEMBER THE FOLLOWING YEAR. BILL
WOULD SPEND TWENTY SIX YEARS OF
HIS CAREER WITH THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN GARDEN GROVE
RISING THE RANK OF LIEUTENANT.
DURING HIS SERVICE LIEUTENANT
DALTON WOULD RECEIVE THE MEDAL
OF VALOR FOR HIS ROLE IN
STOPPING AN ARMED ROBBERY.
EVENTUALLY HE RETIRED FROM THE
POLICE FORCE AND BEGIN SERVING
THE COMMUNITY AS AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL. HE SERVED ON THE
GARDEN GROVE CITY COUNCIL FROM
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT TO TWO
THOUSAND FOUR. AND AS THE
CITY'S MAYOR FROM TWO THOUSAND
FOUR TWO THOUSAND TEN. HIS TIME
AS MAYOR WAS MARKED BY. CITI
UPGRADES. AND TRANSPORTATION
FUNDED BY TOURISM DOLLARS- HIS
GRAND CHILDREN ATTENDED SCHOOL
WITH WITH MY CHILDREN. HE WAS.
A AN EXAMPLE FOR ALL OF US WHO
ASPIRE TO SERVE THE PUBLIC.
FIGHTS WITH GRATITUDE THAT WE
RISE IN WITH SYMPATHY TO HIS
WIFE OF FIFTY NINE YEARS SANDY
IS SIX CHILDREN PATRICIA.
WILLIAMS JUNIOR BILLY JUNIOR.
PAMELA PAUL- ROBERT BRYAN IS
FOURTEEN GRANDCHILDREN
SEVENTEEN GREAT GRANDCHILDREN
THANK YOU CALLING FOR JOIN ME
TO JOIN HIS MEMORY. PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD TO THE
DESK AS WELL SO THAT WE CAN
MEMORIALIZE HIM. SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS IT IS WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT DEPUTY JEFFREY MCKEE
WHOSE END OF WATCH WAS MARCH
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
DEPUTY MCKEE WAS BORN IN CHINO
WHERE HE EXCELLED IN BASEBALL
IT HAD A LOVE FOR MUSIC SERVING
AS A CHINO HIGH SCHOOL BAND
DRUM MAJOR. HE TRULY LOVED HIS
COMMUNITY AND HAD VERY STRONG
ROOTS THROUGHOUT THE CHINO
VALLEY. AFTER GRADUATING HIGH
SCHOOL IN TWO THOUSAND THREE
JEFFREY BECAME AN EMT SERVING
THE COMMUNITY THAT HE LOVED.
THREE YEARS LATER IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX JEFFREY BECAME A
WELL RESPECTED MEMBER OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND TOOK EXTREME
PRIDE IN PLAYING TAPS FOR
FALLEN DEPARTMENT PERSONNEL.
JEFFREY LIVED LIFE THE FULL.
AND ENJOY THE OUTDOORS WITH HIS
FAMILY. RAISING CHICKENS GOATS
AND A DONKEY ON HIS FARM. HE
WILL BE GREATLY MISSED BY HIS
WIFE BRANDY. HIS SON HUNTER AS
DAUGHTER REMY LAN MOTHER LINDA
FATHER BOB AND MANY OTHER
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. MEMBERS BY
ELSA TODAY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY
THANK YOU. PLEASE BRING HIS
NAME FORWARD TO THE DESK SO
THAT HE MAY BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE SENATE.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS SENATOR
ALAN. YET THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LIKE TO ASK THAT WE
MOVE ITEM TWENTY TWO SP CITY
FOURTEEN ACTIVE FILE. SORTER.
SENATOR EDMUND. CORRECTION TO
OUR COMMITTEE START TIME IS
GONNA BE AT TEN FORTY FIVE SO
NO THREE TWO OR THREE VERY GOOD
SEVEN NOTED. IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS. SENATOR BATES
THE DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL ALL
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESSES RECEIVED
BY THE DESK AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO
PM IN A LITTLE REMINDER THAT
NEXT WEEK WE WILL HAVE SESSION
ON FRIDAY SO IT IS A LONG WEEK.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE WILL BE
IN RECESS UNTIL ALL AGES STATED
BUSINESS IS RECEIVED BY THE
DESK AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY
AT TWO PM. SAFE TRAVELS.